I think anytime you experience sort of
pain or hurt or you know something from
from a certain situation going into it
again
you're definitely you know you're
definitely a little gotten you've got a
card up so I think I've definitely been
the type of person to have always have
one up but I think yeah maybe more so
now but I don't know there will be
somebody that comes along that knocks it
down
[Music]
I do want to talk about this new project
with you it's called half written story
it's out now what was it like to release
this amid a pandemic I mean did you find
obstacles challenges and they you did
push it back by a week initially yeah
well it actually had been I mean pushed
for more than that
unbeknownst to my fans it's been a long
time coming as far as you know obviously
putting the project together and then
releasing it um you know definitely had
mixed feelings about the timing of
things but I do feel that music has such
a unique ability of connecting people
and bringing people joy and happiness
it's such a huge form of release for me
[Music]
you do get very personal on this project
in the lyrics and and I'm just curious
what it's like to have your story out
there now I mean it's so much it's
equally as terrifying as it is sort of
you know exciting and liberating um you
know I guess there are artists and and
songs that I relate to and I think it's
because of how transparent and honest
that person is is being and you know
there are so many songs that I listen to
I think oh my god like I never listened
to this song this way before had I you
know and and I wouldn't have had I not
gone through what I went through so I do
think it's just having the courage to be
able to speak your truth and and one
thing I love about having released these
records is that I've had so many people
write to me or you know talk to me about
how they went through similar situations
or they felt exactly what I might have
been feeling when I wrote a specific
lyric and they told me that I make them
feel less alone and the reality for me
is that putting out there is obviously
very scary but at the end of the day
they sort of I guess truly make me feel
like I'm not alone in what I was going
through which is pretty special
it's for to me oh it's I'm the only one
who sees you so venting
so he fishes when you're writing these
lyrics and and telling your story does
it help you to process the emotions that
you are going through you look at
songwriting as a way to sort of overcome
certain things I do I do I mean I
definitely think writing in general has
always been something I've done whether
it was something that no one saw or
heard or you know the opposite I've
always found it to be very sort of
cathartic but yeah I mean it is it is
really it's really amazing when you get
to turn it into song form and one that's
good enough for people to listen to so
that that's always pretty rewarding
[Music]
you said it's terrifying and exciting
but you just say terrifying so I'm
curious was there ever like any patient
on your end about putting some of these
songs out um no not really I mean no I
wouldn't say hesitation obviously there
was the you know nervousness that comes
with releasing anything you're proud of
or have put you know a certain amount of
you know yourself and your time and your
energy into um but I I made a promise
and a commitment to myself when it came
to writing this project that I was gonna
be as honest as I could for me um and I
figured you know listen if there's
anything I want to change I can always
change it no one will ever know because
that's that's something we can do but I
I didn't I was really happy with you
know everything I said and I do feel
like at the end of the day you know
these records were written at a time
where I was or over the course of a time
where one day I was really angry and
frustrated and the next day I was
feeling so alone and isolated and
introverted and the next it's like a
little bit more empowered and a little
bit more confident and sort of starting
to gain you know my self back and I just
loved that I was able to accomplish all
of those emotions that I was going
through in you know a small body of work
it's it's funny that you bring that up
because I noticed like such a range of
emotion like from song to song in one
song you you say like my brother hates
you my mother hates me and my father and
sister too I don't even have a sister
but if I did she'd hate you but then in
wrong direction you say you don't hate
that person
you
no I couldn't
what did you learn about love and like
the intense emotions that come that come
with love while you are writing this
well I think every every love is
different every relationship is
different and sometimes a person is a
certain way in a relationship versus
outside of that relationship and
sometimes you get to know both sides of
that person I guess I just learned how
important it is to be honest and
realistic with yourself I think a lot of
times I mean I've been in situations
where I will choose to ignore certain
things I know deep down aren't
necessarily right or don't make me feel
the way I know I deserve or should feel
and then beyond that you know you start
to sort of try and combine things that
can distract you from the pain that
you're feeling and and again yeah I
guess it's like I've learned not to
ignore that and trust your instincts and
trust yourself and and you know know
that it's okay to feel what you're
feeling it's not wild it sure is
[Music]
you of course say in I love yous like no
more I love yous until I'm okay are you
okay now
I'm so good um and I love I love that
song so much and I kind of love to think
of that one it's like the thesis
statement of the project because that's
kind of how it all started I realized
that for the first time the only thing
that was gonna make me feel okay was
time and that's time to focus on myself
and sort of regain my what's the word
I'm looking for just sense of self I
guess do you want to find love again in
the future like are you more hesitant do
you feel like you have those walls up
and and what kind of are you looking for
now that you've learned so much I mean
yeah for sure okay why all those love
can be it is pretty awesome I wouldn't
say I'm necessarily looking I always
think that and at least in my life it's
proven to be true more than once
that you know kind of comes when you're
not looking for it you know but as far
as like having a guard up I think that's
always been the kind of person I've I am
and I've been for ever with any
relationship but I do think that yeah I
mean I definitely I think anytime you
experience sort of pain or hurt or you
know something from from a certain
situation going into it again you're
definitely happy you know you're
definitely a little gotten you've got
guard up so I think I've definitely been
the type of person to have always have
one off but I think yeah maybe more so
now but I don't know there will be
somebody that comes along that knocks it
down tour plans were there tour plans in
place that you were working on and what
does that look like now luckily there
were there were no tour dates in place
obviously just a bunch of promo runs and
a lot of traveling and I'm not entirely
sure what that looks like now I don't
know that really anybody has the answer
which is you know
it's it's crazy I feel very lucky that I
was able to put the music out and people
are listening to it and enjoying it and
I would do anything and everything to
perform these new songs live so whenever
that may be however it may be hopefully
it happens to Nitin later where there
talks of you possibly performing at
lover fest I know you and Taylor are
friends you guys are also label mates
yeah no not not um no but that sounds
incredible she's obviously amazing and
that album is it's perfect she just I
don't know how she manages to outdo
herself every single time but she does
it's a man well before we wrap things up
going back to the EP it is called half
written story so what is the other half
of your story look like if it were up to
you oh if it were up to me um the other
half of my story is still being written
and I'm still figuring out what that is
yeah figuring it out as I go but um just
living my life taking my time doing me
whatever happens happens and I write
about it so soon find out did you when
you put the album out did you get any
sort of apology phone call angry phone
calls no I got nothing a lot of fans
showing me a lot of love
[Music]